I know the opportunities that came my way
as a, as a result of learning languages.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here today,
I want to talk about how language and
learning languages has changed my life.
Um, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
You know, I was thinking about
this the other day, because here
I am, I'm 76 and, uh, when I was
17, I spoke English essentially.
And, uh, then I got very
interested in French.
And so how did that change my life?
It changed my life because I was
able to convert myself into a
fluent speaker of another language.
I realized at the age of say
18 that that was possible.
And then I ended up going to France.
And so I experienced living in France
getting to know French culture.
Uh, and sort of with that, I was
able to travel into Spain and get a
sense of Spanish, Spanish culture,
Spanish people, the country.
And then I went to China and
learned, or at least to Hong Kong,
and learned Mandarin Chinese,
and that's a whole other world.
And then I lived in Japan and having
learned the Chinese characters I was
able to learn Japanese and lived there
for nine years and got into the culture,
particularly as it applies to wood
because I was in the wood business.
And all of these things...
and then I could go on and on and on of
course, most recently, um, first of all,
learning Russian, uh, at the age of 60
and then moving from there into other
Slavic languages, discovering so much
about those cultures and those people.
And more recently, my Persian and Arabic
again, which brings those people to life.
And because I learn the language,
I get interested in the culture.
I just finished reading a book
about an Iranian lady who won
the Nobel peace prize in 2003.
I think her name is, uh, Edabi
and so, you know, how has
language learning changed my life?
So, you know, maybe I've
missed out on certain things.
If I hadn't learned those languages,
maybe I would have learned something else
that would have brought me great joy.
So you never know about the opportunities
that you missed, but I know the
opportunities that came my way as
a, as a result of learning language.
Yeah.
First of all, opportunities say
professionally, I was able to, I got
my job initially with the government
because I was fluent in French.
Um, I was assigned to Hong Kong to
learn Mandarin Chinese by the, uh, trade
commissioner service and, um, so that
was connected with my, with my work.
And then I, I worked in Japan.
I got a job in Japan and I
built my business based on
understanding the Japanese market.
So there's all of that, but
it's much, much more than that.
It's a perspective on different
cultures, as different as say, Korean,
Chinese, Russian uh, Brazilian, uh, you
know, Greek, Romanian and, and having
touched, you know, in, you know, very
superficially or in greater depth, each
of these cultures that make up the 20
languages that I have either learned or
dabbled in, it brings me so much, uh,
perspective, um, you know, uh, a sense
of participating in so many different
ways of, of looking at our world.
So learning languages and one leads
to another has fundamentally changed
my life, whether that was the best
possible course that I could have
followed in my life who knows.
You lead the life that you lead.
But, uh, certainly for me, languages has
been an enormous part of my life and the
opportunity to, uh, you know, start LingQ,
to work on LingQ with my son and develop
a platform where people learn languages.
We have 42 languages there now for people
to learn and as a platform, which I use to
learn and to continue learning languages.
And you know, here I am, it's my third
career at age 76, I can't wait every
day to be able to get, you know, my
Arabic or my, uh, Persian and, uh, even
to get to know a little bit about, you
know, Egyptian Arabic versus Levantine
Arabic versus Modern Standard Arabic,
which were just terms for me before.
But now that I get into those
languages, I see what's, what's behind
those terms and the cultures that
are behind those terms and so forth.
So I just thought I'd go through that
because you know, a lot of people learn
languages for very practical reasons um,
English is the most popular language.
At least the one that has learned by or
studied by the greatest number of people,
because it's the most important sort of
international language of communication.
But, uh, if you follow my channel, you
know that I always encourage people
to learn more than one language.
And the benefit is not only the
enjoyment of, of the learning process
itself, but also what you come up with.
Even if you end up forgetting some of
the languages that you have learned,
but at least for the time that you were
learning those languages and discovering
those languages, you were entering,
entering into a, another world, uh, a
rich world that up to that point was
relatively unknown, at least to me.
So just a brief ramble.
I was just thinking about how lucky I
was that back some, you know, 50...60,
60 years ago, I got totally wrapped up
in learning French, which then led to
another and yet another and yet another,
and I'm very happy that I did that.
So just thought I would share
those thoughts with you.
Thank you for listening.